[archive audio] Helen Sharman becoming the
first Brit in space. She blasted off with
two Soviet cosmonaut repair men on a mission
designed chiefly to repair the ageing Mir
space station, that has been orbiting the
globe for five years now.
[Helen Sharman] This is my Sokol space
suit. Only used for the emergency situation
that the air would actually leak out of the
spacecraft. We wear it for the dangerous
times: the launch, the docking, and then the
landing again.
It's got to be strong so that if it does inflate
with air or oxygen and you've got nothing
around you, it's to stop it just blowing up
like a balloon and exploding. So it's strengthened
with wires in various places, which generally
means it's not the most comfortable thing
to stand up in, because it's designed to actually
sit inside your seat, with you hunched up
like this.
-There's a great assortment of bits and pieces:
valves, knobs, cables. Do you want to take
us through what all these do?
-The big blue valve on the front is really
useful: If you do inflate the space suit and
then you have to do some manoeuvre, which
might be difficult to do because you've inflated,
you can decrease the pressure, you check this
little valve on the suit's arm to see what
pressure you've decreased it to. From memory
that goes to about 0.26 of an atmosphere,
but that's not really very much oxygen to
breathe, so you can do that only for a short
time before you then need to rest again. You
then use the blue valve on the front to increase
the pressure back up to 0.4 of an atmosphere,
and that's enough for you to breathe and survive.
You can do that repeatedly until you've got
the manoeuvre done.
-When you are in it and trying to work, how
easy is it?
-It's uncomfortable. Typically, astronauts
lose about 2 litres of sweat just during the
launch phase because, as you can see, where
are you going to lose heat from? If you can
open your helmet you can get a bit of ventilation
on your head. There are ventilation holes
just underneath the rim of the helmet that
will enable air to come up past your face,
that not only keep you cool but stop your
helmet from misting up as well.
-You're onboard Mir for the first time: can
you tell me remember what was going through
your mind?
-Once you've docked and made sure you're not
leaking air from the seal, you can then open
the hatch and float inside. It's lovely to
be able to float into these long thing modules,
and just go all the way down. And then this
wonderful way that you can just stretch out.
You get used to weightlessness so easily.
Within seconds you forget what it's like to
stand and feel the pressure of the floor beneath
your feet. And you adopt naturally a different
way of moving; you tend to hold things between
your knees or feet and then manoeuvre through
the space station with your arms, which is
of course the reverse of on earth, where you'd
walk with your feet and hold things with your
hands. You just naturally do that.
When I look back now, it was very much a personal
thing. I remember my colleagues, I remember
some of those details like just floating by
a window and all coming together in the evening
and talking and looking out. It's those personal
times you remember. We did a job of work,
but as with any job when you look back over
what you've done in the last year, do you
really remember that report you wrote for
your boss? Actually you remember your colleagues
and your interactions with them mostly.